des jeunes femmes les jeunes filles au
pouvoir entrer à l'école polytechnique
29 avril 1970 une loi est votée les
femmes auront désormais le droit de
passer le concours d'entrée de l'école
polytechnique dans le contexte post 68
c'est une vraie révolution
et c'est michel debré alors ministre de
la défense qui a défendu ce projet c'est
d'ailleurs lui qui avait permis
l'ouverture aux femmes d'une autre
grande école l'ena à l'issue de l'école
polytechnique il ya certaines
administrations qui peuvent je crois
aisément accueillir les jeunes filles
mais cette réforme ne fait pas que des
heureux par exemple le président de la
commission de la défense à l'assemblée
nationale craignait que l'entrée des
filles ne nuise à cette école militaire
et l'expliquer non sans une dose de
sarcasme
on est quand même pas tout à fait pour
l'égalité
c'est peut-être parce que j'aime
beaucoup les femmes que je les crois
supérieur et donc pas légal
il faudra attendre encore deux ans pour
que la réforme se met en place
ce n'est donc qu'en 1972 que les femmes
passent pour la première fois le
concours d'entrée de polytechnique
et c'est d'ailleurs une femme anne
chopinet qu'ils aient reçu major
invraisemblable pour ce journaliste de
la rtbf n'a pas l'impression qu'on vous
prenne un peu pour un monstre et qu'on
s'éloigne de nous pendant près de trois
minutes
un florilège de questions misogyne et
vous ferez vol ce que vous trouvez les
magasins est ce que vous occupez un
petit peu
à la veille de la rentrée scolaire dans
cette école surnommé l'x de 17 filles
sur 315 élèves de la promo sont invités
dans les jt pour des questions
pertinentes exemple parce que plus tard
la sortie d'école vous épouser oreiller
un élève vix major de sa promo c'est
comme le veut la tradition une chopine
et qui porte le drapeau lors du défilé
du 14 juillet 1973 il va sans dire que
madame pompidou et toutes les
représentantes du sexe dit faible qui
regardaient mademoiselle chopinet
l'applaudir chaleureusement une forte
médiatisation qui ne va pas démocratisé
l'entrée des filles dans l'école en 1997
alors qu'elle représente moins de 15%
des élèves le directeur de l'école
lançait un appel
je suis en général qui réclament des
filles à l'école polytechnique un peu
plus
malgré ses appels malgré des dispositifs
mis en place au sein de l'école pour
attirer plus d'étudiants tu le
pourcentage de filles n'a jamais dépassé
les 20%
[Musique]